the first day of the new right-wing
reality for Italy and feelings are mixed
well I expect more political
self-determination for Italy now within
the limits of the European Union's roles
to let ourselves be heard with a more
decisive voice
someone who voted for her because
of her of the right but this doesn't
mean that I think the country wanted to
show once again a rebellion I think that
every collector's political campaign was
completely wrong he wasn't the right
person and I'm sorry for the Italians
who voted for him because it was evident
he would have lost
politically the central left Democratic
party came second behind Georgia
Maloney's Brothers of Italy but it's all
about Coalition politics here which
means they will be in the opposition
today is a sad day for Italy for Europe
tough days lie ahead we fought as much
as we could to avoid this outcome we
fought for our values and with the into
taking Italy into the future
Melania dressed her supporters in the
early hours of Monday morning saying she
would represent all Italians and unite
the country her right-wing Coalition
gained around 44 of the vote meaning it
will hold a majority in both houses of
Parliament she has good reasons to to be
happy of course because the the party
was so successful 26 percent
of the votes which is huge result
actually the greatest result of a
radical right party in Europe but at the
same time she has some good news to be
worried about the stability of her
government new government and this is
due to the fact that the other partners
of the Coalition did not so well and
this might result even in a crisis of
the league and the crisis of the
leadership of the party right now
Italian media across the political
Spectrum have called it a historic win
an earthquake in the country's politics
Milani takes Italy but Georgia Maloney's
party has no previous government
experience and considering the many
challenges facing Italy like the energy
and economic crisis and the soaring cost
of living winning may just have been the
easy part Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera
Roe